- We're out here on the
streets of Hollywood
asking people how much they
know about their favorite music.
But first we gotta talk to
people with headphones in.
Typically those people don't want to talk.
Excuse me, excuse me.
Excuse me sir.
Excuse me, no, okay.
We're gonna get them to talk.
(upbeat music)
What kind of music do you listen to?
- I'm listening to the Burlesque album,
the movie with Cher
and Christina Aguilera.
- Right now I'm listening
to The Weekend (laughing).
- The Weekend, that's fine, that's good,
you shouldn't be embarrassed
about that, he's great.
What music are you listening to?
- I was listening to a band called Death.
- How much do you know about Death?
- Quite a bit.
- Yeah.
- [Man In Black Shirt] Yeah.
- Do you feel like if I were
to quiz you, you could nail it?
- Hopefully.
- Okay.
Christina Aguilera, she's great.
Do you know where Christina
Aguilera was born?
I'll even Google it, I'll
Google it while you guess.
Where do you think
Christina Aguilera was born?
Think of some context clues,
like Christina Aguilera.
She's like a blonde.
Do you know where The Weekend is from?
- Cananda.
- Damn girl.
So Christina Aguilera was either born in
Kentucky, New York, or Florida.
Which would you guess?
- I'd say Kentucky.
- Kentucky, you're wrong.
It's Staten Island, New York
but I mean, who would know that?
So who is your favorite country artist?
- Hank Williams Jr.
- Hank Williams Jr.?
- Absolutely.
- That's a great choice.
Do you know how old he is?
- He'd be, right now, probably about 71.
- 71 that's a little over, it's 67.
Not bad though,
- [Man In Hat] Oh man.
that's pretty close.
So you were just listening to
some music right there, right?
- Yes.
- What were you listening to?
- Mandy Moore.
- Oh Mandy Moore?
- Yeah.
- [Man] Oh wow,
what is she up to?
This isn't a question,
this is just me wondering.
What was Mandy Moore's first big single?
- Oh that's so hard, Candy?
- You did it.
- [Girl] Was it Candy?
- That's it, it's Candy.
- [Girl] Are you serious?
- Yeah, you did it, me neither.
Who do you listen to the
most that's not like a DJ,
but like a band?
- MF Doom.
- Is it Mother (bleep) Doom?
- Yeah.
(Chuckling)
- Okay, I listen to Slander EDM.
- Who are the members of Slander?
- The members of Slander.
Eric Adam.
- You wonder like Eric Adams right?
- Yeah.
- It's Derek Anderson.
- Oh Derek Anderson.
- Very close, and then Scott
Land which, never been there.
Sounds like a beautiful place though,
Scott Land,
- [Man With Beard] Scott Land
sounds incredible.
- [Man With Beard] (laughing)
I don't know how you would
know that, but Google knew.
- (laughing) Google knows everything.
- Google knows everything.
That's just the truth, now you know that.
- Okay.
- We're more informed.
- [Girl] Yeah, thank
you for the information.
- Thank you for appreciating
the information.
What's your other favorite band?
- Megadeth.
- Megadeth, staying in
the same death theme.
(guitar plucking)